absolutely and in clear first right now
hikaru
uh
this might have been your hardest day in
terms of talent you had to play against
which included fabiano and wesley so
that you managed to score two wins big
wins out of three the other one against
lania dominguez how do you feel you're
playing right now you seem like you're
pretty much in shape yeah i mean i've
played a lot on the internet so i assume
it transfers over to the board um
you know i think as far as uh the
fabiano game i mean it would have been
nice if he could have done this in isle
of man in 2019 rather than playing it
here today uh because this is a line i
had looked at uh even back then of
course in the game he played at petrov
it was a draw i didn't qualify for the
candidates and you know i became a
streamer instead so
uh things could have gone a lot
differently um
but but yeah so i had this idea from
2019 i think for fabiano he wasn't he
didn't know exactly how to play it and
it was just very unpleasant and
eventually i mean he kind of just cracks
he had he had no time so it was very
good
uh and then lenny's game i mean it's
just just computers i mean you look at a
position as a human it's very scary with
the computer the computer just laughs at
you and shows like five different ways
to equalize but over the board if you
don't know it's very difficult so two
very good games for me
two very good games and a very good day
very good standing
blitz coming up everybody knows you're
the best blitz player in the world you
must really like your chances right now
um yeah i mean i i think i have good
chances again blitz is a little bit
different than rapid and the one thing i
would say is that
uh in this event i actually use a lot of
time in in many games which is one thing
i normally haven't done in my you know
over the course of my career so
uh you know perhaps it could be a little
bit tricky getting getting back into
form but again i think that uh being
being in the lead even is is a really
good spot to be and uh we'll see how it
goes you had one grand chess tour event
i think it was paris 2016 you were
competing against magnus you managed to
win that with the lead have you had
another grandchild victory other than
that one oh i think i want to wrap it in
blitz here in st louis i think in 2018
maybe i don't know 2018
yeah something like that but but anyway
i think i think what i would say is uh
i i just felt i was very solid i i
played pretty well and if you're solid
and you take take advantage of your
opportunities when they present
themselves you know good things tend to
happen and uh i don't think i was ever
really in much danger except for maybe
the game against the quang so it's uh
it's very good you feeling uh
anything at all about being a spoiler
for the the guys who are actually on the
grand chester uh watching them step back
a little bit maxim is really pleased to
see you at the top uh
i didn't actually think about this if i
did not cross my mind you know i just
enjoying the event playing and
you know you play good chess good things
happen and i i feel like overall i i as
i said the other day i'm playing with
house money not really concerned so if i
play well and good things happen you
know good for maxime maybe bad for
fabiano but that's how it goes all right
well congratulations on how you're
playing and look forward to seeing you
show your skills in the blitz thank you
hikaru if you don't mind me asking you
mentioned that this this line this idea
uh was prepped by you for some time ago
uh
share with us the the thought process
that brought you to knight d2
and this whole
i want to say pressure that you kept on
him uh just just hit the space bar
computer gives you the best one
but yeah what i what i know is that i
mean i had this
i i guess you know it's it's like if i
looked at lenny and what i did it's good
for a game and now everyone will go home
look at it and it won't be good for the
next game and the same thing applies to
the fabiano game so what i would say is
that um
if you go forward to this bishop f4 this
is all still all still prep um
yeah castle's bishop f4 and here instead
of rookie 88 i think rick g8 is supposed
to draw
there's like a very long sequence with
like rook g8 i think it goes bishop g3
knight e7 rook c1
c6 d5 or g4 you take the juicer on h7
um
and then work c4
and it's a very long line where it
should it should be a draw but again
like you know is it practical for
for for some defiance over the board and
rapid game i i don't think so in a
classical game maybe but if but in rapid
it's just nobody's gonna nobody's gonna
find these sorts of ideas gotcha is that
the secret find ideas
that top players just may not work out
like just find those lines at the
computer says you gotta find these moves
or else yeah i mean basically that's the
idea i think in classical chess 2 the
only problem is when someone is two
hours it's a lot easier to think and
figure it out when you can take 30
minutes versus having to take maybe 10
or 15 at most um you know i would say
lenny game is a better example where if
lenny had two hours he he for sure would
have found something better than what he
did in the game with this knight takes
d5 and queen b and probably it would
have been a draw so you try to do it in
both but definitely in rapid it's um it
can be much more effective
if your opponent's surprised
all right thanks for those insights
thank you hikara good luck in the blitz
absolutely well it'll be a pleasure to
see him there